What makes the perfect human immaculate
features indomitable intelligence in
comparable wit or irresistible charm.
How about all of the above?
What if you could modify your genes?
What if everyone could?
What are the consequences of being better?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen
if genetically modified
people became the norm.
Many bacteria are able to combat viral
infection with a defense system called
Crispr CRISPR records,
viral DNA that a bacteria has been
exposed to and enables a protein complex
called cas nine to basically search
for the viral DNA and destroy it.
Enter Dr Jennifer Doudna who started
research and Crispr in 2005 by 2012 she
cofounded CRISPR cas nine a life changing
technology that allows humans to edit
genes as more research on CRISPR
comes forward so to new possibilities.
Could we cure genetic diseases?
Could we cut out cancer?
Could I finally get the Blue Eyes?
I've always wanted,
but what happens when gene editing goes
too far for genetically modified people
to become the norm? Gene editing
wouldn't only have to be legal.
It would have to be relatively affordable.
Some countries might even choose to
subsidize it for life saving medical
procedures.
After all,
technology like CRISPR cas nine may be
able to be used to prevent any genetic
disease or disability we know of today,
the genes responsible for Huntington's
disease or cystic fibrosis can be wiped
out and prevent it from being passed on.
Economics aside,
every newborn could have the chance
to live a normal, healthy life.
Imagine creating a super race of people.
If everyone on the planet was genetically
engineered to be the strongest version
of themselves, would we still have
competitions like the Olympics?
If we could modify the
intelligence of everyone on earth,
could we solve all of
humanity's greatest challenges?
Could it finally be your turn
to be Miss Universe or the hulk,
but as Crispr cas nine really a cure
all or a catch 22 when you use CRISPR to
edit out unwanted jeans, you destroy
thousands of DNA bases in one go.
Yes,
CRISPR is pretty precise,
but there's still a risk that you could
silence some genes that are meant to be
active and activate genes
that are meant to be dormant.
What researchers are finding is that
in trying to save yourself through gene
editing, you might just cut
out a key anticancer mechanism.
Not only does CRISPR pose a cancer risk,
but in reprogramming or rearranging DNA,
we might even end up
creating new diseases.
Whether it's a new procedure or routine
operation or an over the counter cold
pill.
We tend to accept the risk of side effects
or complications if it means getting
better.
But with gene editing,
don't you think that getting
better might get a bit weird?
What happens when parents start to
choose their kid's height, eye color,
hair color, skin, pigment, or gender?
What happens when those with financial
means can buy better cures that are
features and ultimately better futures?
Well,
that future if possible,
is very far away.
CRISPR technology is still in its
infancy and our understanding of genes is
still too limited to start choosing
height and hair color. It will eye color,
hair color,
height,
and other physical features are
associated with a combination of genes,
not just one, but forget science
for a moment. Ask Yourself,
which is more important,
pure cold perfection or true
emotional human connection.
It might not be perfect,
but it certainly can't be hacked.